chiudete gli occhi si ecco magari non
troppo so che il pranzo in via un po
appesantito chiudete gli occhi e
immaginate l'estate
immaginate di fare una passeggiata in
montagna
e immaginate di trattenervi un po più a
lungo del solito per guardare le stelle
lontano dall'inquinamento luminoso
cittadino vi stendete su una coperta e
cercate di individuare le costellazioni
conosciute e i pianeti visibili il suono
degli animali della notte vi tiene
compagnia in sottofondo armonioso che
accompagna il flusso dei vostri pensieri
in questo universo di stelle i pianeti
di galassie possiamo spingerci oltre i
confini della nostra conoscenza possiamo
spingerci oltre i confini terrestri
andare lassù ed esplorare il cielo che
vediamo da qui c'è qualcuno su uno di
quei pianeti che vediamo che sta
guardando il suo cielo e si sta
chiedendo se noi esistiamo
siamo davvero l'unica forma di vita
possibile
beh queste domande sono state poste a
molteplici volte nel corso dei secoli
fin dagli antichi greci
forse per trovare delle risposte
quello di cui abbiamo bisogno a partire
da ciò che conosciamo
e allora cos'è che già sappiamo sappiamo
che ogni pianeta un suo sole e così come
il nostro sole a otto pianeti che gli
ruotano intorno allo stesso modo molte
delle stelle che vediamo la sua
potrebbero avere pianeti che ruotano
loro intorno
in effetti è così negli ultimi 20 anni
gli scienziati hanno scoperto migliaia
di pianeti
alcuni come giove giganti gassosi
gli altri più piccoli rocciosi come la
terra e allora in queste in questa
moltitudine di stelle in questa
moltitudine di pianeti forse è possibile
che esista la vita là fuori anche se
ancora non ne abbiamo l'evidenza come
scoprirlo allora è un sistema planetario
al di fuori del nostro ci appare un po
come una città lontana di cui vediamo le
luci che brillano a distanza ma di cui
non possiamo percorrere le strade
tuttavia guardando osservando quelle
luci che brillano possiamo ottenere
delle informazioni su come le stelle ei
pianeti che ruotano loro intorno
formino possano interagire fra di loro
per formare un ecosistema che permetta
la vita per esempio quando un pianeta
ruota intorno al sole a una stella
blocca parte della luce che questa
stella e mette e che noi riceviamo
produce quindi delle oscillazioni nell
intensità luminosa e da queste
oscillazioni dell'intensità luminosa di
una stella possiamo non solo avere
informazioni riguardo la presenza del
pianeta ma anche riguarda la sua
dimensione o riguardo alla distanza fra
il pianeta è la stella andar a quello
che possiamo fare è disegnare delle
mappe di stelle delle mappe di pianeti
quei pianeti abitabili cioè non troppo
grandi e non troppo piccoli non troppo
caldi non troppo freddi insomma quelli
giusti per ospitare la vita
un po come la terra la terra perché la
terra cosa la terra di così speciale
la terra un pallido puntina blu nel
vasto universo come l'ha definita
l'astronomo americano carl sagan un
puntino blu indistinguibile da tutti gli
altri
eppure unico l'unico pianeta in grado di
ospitare la vita come noi la conosciamo
e non un solo tipo di vita 8,7 milioni
di specie diverse di cosa hanno bisogno
questi 8,7 milioni di spese per vivere
quindi perché la terra e così speciale
la risposta a queste domande è
incredibilmente semplice questi 8,7
milioni di specie per vivere sul nostro
pianeta hanno bisogno solo di tre
ingredienti hanno bisogno di energia
possiamo pensare alle piante che usano
la luce del sole come fonte di energia
per la fotosintesi clorofilliana per
produrre zucchero ossigeno hanno bisogno
di nutrimento e tutte le 8,7 milioni di
specie viventi sul nostro pianeta
traggono la maggior parte del loro
nutrimento solo da sei elementi chimici
tutti i nati nelle stelle che vediamo
lassù e poi hanno bisogno di acqua e non
ghiaccio non vapore ma acqua liquida
pensate ci siamo fatti per il 60 per
cento di acqua
questo è ciò che serve alla vita per
resistere sul nostro pianeta
ma cosa intendiamo per vita abbiamo una
definizione di vita
ecco non è così facile dare una
definizione dal punto di vista
scientifico e non voglio certo ad
entrarmi nell'ambito semantico di questo
discorso però riconoscerete con bechi è
molto più facile distinguere ciò che è
vivo da ciò che non lo è possiamo per
esempio distinguere fra una farfalla e
un cristallo in cristallo non è vivo una
farfalla lo è
eppure negli ultimi 150 anni gli
scienziati hanno reso molto meno netta
la distinzione fra ciò che è vivo e ciò
che non lo è
è un po come se io vi chiedessi di dirmi
dove è che comincia il viola in questo
gradiente che va dal rosso al blu
qualcuno potrebbe dirmi nel centro ma
qualcuno potrebbe dirmi un po più in
alto un po più a destra un po più in
basso e non avrebbe torto
pensavo adesso ad un virus virus è un
sistema naturale sistema semplice e
molto semplice forse troppo semplice
infatti non ho tutte quelle
caratteristiche tutte quelle proprietà
che un essere vivente ha bisogno per
essere considerato vivo quindi infatti
per esempio ha bisogno è un parassita ha
bisogno di altri
esseri viventi per riprodursi quindi un
virus è vivo oppure non lo è come
facciamo a rispondere a questa domanda
come facciamo a scoprire se qualcosa
vivo oppure no
abbiamo due possibilità un approccio più
tradizionale possiamo prendere tutte
quelle 8,7 milioni di specie e possiamo
cercare di individuare quali sono quelle
proprietà che hanno tutte in comune che
le rendono vive
oppure possiamo capire ciò che è vivo
costruendolo così come mescolando i
giusti ingredienti possiamo preparare
una torta possiamo mescolare i
mattoncini fondamentali alla base delle
nostre cellule e costruire qualcosa di
più complesso che definiremmo vivo e se
sì come i mattoncini fondamentali alla
base delle cellule delle nostre cellule
sono tre sistema che contiene un
informazione il dna
un sistema che faccia da motore produca
energia le proteine e un sistema che
racchiuda il tutto per renderlo un
entità individuale la membrana
tuttavia come questi tre questi tre
mattoncini siano emersi sul nostro
pianeta e si siano poi evoluti fino a
quello che abbiamo adesso non lo
sappiamo
cinque anni fa ha cominciato il
dottorato di ricerca qui a trento e mi
sono incuriosita è interessata ad una di
questi mattoncini le proteine le
proteine svolgono molteplici attività si
occupano di metabolismo si occupano di
ricevere e rispondere a stimoli esterni
di trasportare ossigeno trasportare
altri nutrienti replicazione di dna
insomma sono un po multitasking
in realtà c'è un tipo particolare di
proteine si chiamano proteine ferro
zolfo sono interessanti perché sono
considerate fra le proteine più antiche
presenti sul nostro pianeta e sono
presenti in quasi tutti gli organismi
viventi
che conosciamo solo che ovviamente
adesso queste proteine sono molto
complesse forse all'inizio non erano
così complesse forse all'inizio erano
solo un insieme di pochi atomi tenuti
insieme fra di loro
queste proteine si chiamano proteine
ferro zolfo proprio perché contengono
due elementi speciali il ferro e lo
zolfo che erano molto presenti
largamente presenti sulla terra
primordiale e è proprio da qui che
comincia la mia storia
beh non proprio così male un po meglio
beh la mia storia comincia con ben più o
meno
vediamo se riusciamo ma è la mia storia
comincia con me che interessa queste
proteine e cerca di capire come queste
proteine sono emerse sulla nostra sul
nostro pianeta
e allora torno a quello di cui parlavo
prima di cosa ha bisogno la vita per
esistere sul nostro pianeta
abbiamo detto tre ingredienti ha bisogno
di nutrimento ha bisogno di acqua
bisogno di energia
allora comincio col prendere questi
elementi il ferro lo zolfo e li metto in
acqua e poi utilizzo la luce del sole
come fonte di energia e quello che
ottengo è una proteina primitiva un
modello di una di quelle proteine che
abbiamo adesso nelle nostre cellule che
di per sé è già entusiasmante perché
queste proteine
adesso vengono costruite nella nostra
cellule grazie ad altre proteine un
sistema altamente efficace e efficiente
ma altamente complesso codificato nel
nostro dna e invece io soltanto
prendendo qualcuno di questi piccoli
elementi mescolandoli con la luce del
sole
ottenuta una proteina primitiva
forse voi potreste dirmi sì beh hai
costruito una proteina primitiva come si
va da quella proteina primitiva alle
nostre cellule moderne
ecco che quindi la mia storia continua
con me che cerco di rendere compatibile
questa mia proteina primitiva con un
altro dei mattoncini di cui abbiamo
parlato prima
la membrana cellulare cioè cerco di
capire se la mia proteina primitiva e
compatibile con la membrana cellulare
cioè cerco di costruire qualcosa intorno
alla mia proteina primitiva che la renda
simile a una cellula moderna ma in
versione semplificata cioè che le le
metto intorno quell'involucro che oggi
contiene tutte le nostre proteine e
tutto il nostro materiale genetico e ha
funzionato ho costruito una proteina
primitiva dentro la cellula primitiva
wow
ma ancora potreste dirmi sì beh hai una
proteina primitiva in una cellula
primitiva la tua prima se hai detto
tante storie su sul fatto che le
proteine svolgono delle attività sono
alla base della contrazione del
rilassamento dei muscoli si occupano
della fotosintesi clorofilliana della
respirazione cellulare
beh fanno cose le proteine e la tua
proteina primitiva può fare cose ecco
che allora cominciò a studiare la mia
proteina primitivo a cercare di capire
se può far qualcosa non solo scopro che
la mia proteina primitiva può fare
qualcosa ha un'attività ma anche che
quell'attività della mia proteina
primitiva è la stessa attività delle
proteine moderne sui discendenti cioè a
favorire il metabolismo con la
respirazione cellulare e produrre un po
di quella energia che viene prodotta
oggi nelle nostre celle da quelle
proteine e che serve per la sintesi
della tp che è il combustibile alla base
delle nostre cellule
e di nuovo wow ha costruito una proteina
primitiva dentro una cella primitiva che
ha la stessa attività delle proteine
moderne nelle cellule moderne
ecco questa è la mia storia ho
ricostruito un modello di cellula
primitiva quello che era disponibile
sulla terra a 4 miliardi e mezzo di anni
fa ha ricostruito un modello di cellula
primitiva che ha qualcosa in comune con
le nostre cellule
ricostruito un modello di cellula
primitiva che ha alcune di quelle
caratteristiche di quelle proprietà che
rendono le nostre cellule le cellule
moderne vive perché costruire una
cellula pezzo per pezzo mattoncino dopo
mattoncino ci può aiutare in due
direzioni la prima è darci qualche
indizio in più sulla transizione di cui
parlavamo prima fra ciò che è vivo e ciò
che non lo è tra cristalli farfalla fra
blu e rosso e poi si può permettere di
capire non solo come la vita possa
essere nata sul nostro pianeta
mattoncino dopo mattoncino ma anche se
sia possibile la vita al di fuori del
nostro pianeta
altrove nell'universo magari emersa in
condizioni diverse in luoghi diversi e
in tempi diversi
ecco questo possa andarvi solo un passo
ho costruito una proteina primitiva ma
come poi questa possa interagire con
altre proteine primitive o possa essere
possa interagire col dna o poi venire a
codificata nel dna
per questo possiamo darvi o solo un
passo in un lungo percorso
eppure è un primo passo e da un grande
passo oltre i confini della nostra
conoscenza perché là fuori c'è qualcosa
di incredibile da scoprire
ad attenderci là fuori
ecco ora vorrei che chiude gli occhi di
nuovo e vi ricordate più quello di cui
vi ho parlato all'inizio d'estate una
passeggiata a guardare le stelle siete
distesi su una coperta
cercate di guardare curiosi di scrutare
il cielo riconoscere le stelle
pensate a quello che vi ho raccontato
oggi
pensate alle migliaia di stelle lassù
alle migliaia di pianeti lassù
pensate alla terra un pallido puntino
blu il vasto universo
pensate alla vita a come potrebbe essere
emersa sul nostro pianeta mattoncino
dopo mattoncino e pensate alla vita a
come potrebbe essere
là fuori pensate a ciò di cui ha bisogno
la vita per emergere qualcosa di così
universale che ci accomuna tutti e
allora parafrasando parafrasando
margherita hack per quanto ogni essere
vivente sia diverso per quanto ognuno
abbia un diverso colore di occhi di
capelli di pelle
abbiamo tutti la stessa origine
discendiamo tutti dall'evoluzione del
nostro pianeta
dall'evoluzione delle stelle dall
evoluzione dell'universo e per questo
siamo tutti fratelli
ecco magari non vi ha convinto a
diventare astronauti o ad interessarvi
di chimica primordiale o di biologia
evolutiva
però vorrei che mi portasse a casa a
casa questo messaggio è che ci pensa ste
la prossima volta che guardate il cielo
lassù siamo tutti i fatti di stelle
dentro di noi
abita un pezzo di universo che ci
accomuna tutti
grazie